it's sad that it really ended up the way
it did because I don't know there's just
a lot of stress the the there's a lot of
sadness there's a lot of like what in
the world
did you do like what happened how did we
get here
I'm still sad that one of the kids don't
have it I don't know yeah well I think
he went crazy or something I I don't
know the details of the negotiations of
what you dealt with the two boys
like for the price of this the kids
can't afford that
now there's a family practice they all
know it
but the thing is Matt you got this a
two-year-old appraisal is what I sold it
for I never expected it to be as much as
this
no offering it to the kids I thought you
would be oh I'm you know a little more
reasonable well the cat no the kids are
getting they just what they don't like
is the fact that it shrunk
[Music]
you know We Shrunk the property size on
board the two boys didn't like that but
you know I got to think about all four
kids there's four kids involved and so
what's fair you know at the end when it
the big pieces you know in a state what
what's the fair thing you could possibly
do
you know what the good news is there's
93 acres in this family
I mean no there's 93 acres for Matt Road
it's not part of the family anymore
growing up you created this image in
them and unfortunately that's a lot
harder to let go because it's in bread
it's it's it's part of you know who they
are
expected the kids to you know to
not take entitlement but to take
um you know start working for it but man
you've got to understand there's a lot
but man you got to understand you can
say that a hundred times
it wasn't like I didn't try to sell to
the kids that have basically half off
family discount but I'm glad that even
with all that they made other decisions
because I don't think the fit was quite
right you know if the kids had gotten it
I would be stuck maintaining that you
know maybe even harder than I do now you
don't admit to anything I do you don't
oh part of this I would say the majority
of this Hornet's net unfortunately
you need to accept lays on your
shoulders okay well I'm taking
responsibility so but you're taking
responsibility of not creating a legacy
there's a lot going on there's a lot
going on that you don't know about
all right so this exercise
all right got it
[Music]